Salma Hayek got some super fat [__]
Juggernaut sloppy tits [__] suck a
month
your word for word dude I don't okay
anyways
but no for real somehow I got some
Victor wendbanyamas
she really she
said oh my god yamas dude oh my God I
was like whipping yummity
ding dong it was crazy diving in that
little pool show them little things
56 I mean that's crazy she's 50 how old
56. hey I don't I don't think so
I think she's 53. she gotta be a good 53
or 52. that's three years there's no way
she's 56. I know I would have 66 year
old tint look like that's not a 56 year
old how do you know dude I know look at
Google her age right now see how old I
didn't know that I know it
56 she was born in 1966 it's from the
60s that's where she's from her parents
[__] in the 60s but here's the thing
Mark when does a woman get to son she's
damn near 57 when is a woman
you say
around puberty
this doesn't happen for a few years so
you got a lot what happens in an
industry yeah you gotta Lop off a good
decade plus from them knocker boots
so them knockables that's an insane
questions damn knocker boots
yo for real how many bot mints does she
need for them titties bro them titties
are minus one five minutes
they didn't start Barnyard bopping into
the teenage years oh so you're saying
titties maybe are 40. I'm saying her
titties probably for premium if we want
to put it 18 to be premium
the starts around 18. do the math you
got to knock 18 years off of that what's
56 minus 18. 38 38 huh that's a 38 year
old set of hot sauce
no that's the 38 year old said hot to
hot
so when you look at them you're like all
right that makes sense yeah these are
just young yeah they are 38 that's Young
ain't nothing younger than 38. 3780
when you think about it when you do the
math you push it like that that's a good
point when you do the math yeah and hey
it ain't Mark do the math go Al is she
crossing your boundaries what does that
mean like if you if this was your shorty
hypothetically speaking could she do
that once you go through menopause once
you have children you go through
metamods you get to do whatever you want
your body surf it up for real surfboard
still having titties like that after you
push a human being out of you bro
you deserve to celebrate you make some
life
you go you go 57 years defy gravity for
38 of them [__] throw them up on the
gram girl you earned it okay okay 23
years your titty's still sitting up by
your chin the way they should be that
ain't nothing to brag about
I don't know
[Laughter]
what is a woman listen what is a woman
when a woman has put her body through
childbirth multiple times and lives to
talk about it and her [__] is still
together show it off she only have one
kid oh
one Mexican
that's it yeah one Mexican kid so you
know if you snuck out of it
documented one but you know two or three
was in there as well like finally we
made it wow
wow look at what we get we get stuck on
later so much fun gonna be really tall
and big you don't even need an ID
anymore no you don't bro that's crazy
come on look where else snuck into this
country bro let's knock himself into his
country house
you didn't even have a password crazy
the crazy thing is that Mom didn't need
a password
why do you think why do you think why
are you so confident she was gonna be
able to get in the country they had the
same [__] age too that's just crazy
my mom had some higher
same ain't no way bro you're pushing the
conversation in this direction
hold on are you saying your mom's got
some Bombs Over
backpacks
that's the kids before
oh she went there giving age bro
I'm talking about bro
come on let's watch her dive into the
pool on that water level rise up
come on
hey what's the next one because hey how
many tities are here we can't
concentrate but we make our best content
I know oh my
there we go what the [__] the Heavies
but that's the thing you get to that age
you should be able to show off your body
like this because it's Unique
oh goodness gracious and the feet and
her billion billionaire husband lets her
do this exactly what do you mean let's
she gets to do whatever she wants bro
she created life bro women that created
life can dress like slots because they
created lives
of course they went through it they've
earned it they put their body through
the grinder which billionaire husband is
she with who's she
the guy who's the founder of um keyring
group or head of caring group Gucci
Saint Laurent Steve McQueen he's like
the lvmh but different group a lot of
money but can we just acknowledge what
women go through bro
y'all don't look at a woman who's like
45 and still in good shape and you're
like God damn good for you yo what you
had to do to to accomplish that the
suffering you had to go through yeah
sure
yeah I'd be like I give them when they
walk by I give them
you beat your chest I
give them just one
you know what I mean out of respect do
they know what you're doing yeah
yeah they'd be like huh they don't get
it but they should
sexually
you know the answer's no I'm just gonna
stop you right there what about should
we be able to sexually also know to that
one no I want to hear it okay should we
be able to sexually comment on women
over 50.
in front of them why not
since they're out of the sexual
experience
like you can't
you can't right so
it can't be that sexual right it's not
like the purpose of sex is obviously
procreation right but so it's like it's
not really but I I know
what are you talking about no but for
real I'm just saying it should be viewed
more as a compliment like [__] there
you Cheerio [__]
[Laughter]
I don't know I don't know where to start
the purpose is saying come on
girl come on girl y'all never jet lagged
and horny come on
don't you think that no you gotta you
just gotta turn gate when a sexy older
woman is walking by oh wow because then
you can say all the show you how do you
do it what do you what are you saying
what do you do
how do you I don't know put up that
video you don't show it up yeah yeah it
was funny when you went up to the dude
bro you gotta say it because
he starts with [__] he's like he says
slay [__] multiple girls
and a [__] or some [__] he just a clean
[__] and he's like [__] ass [__]
you're gonna see us whoa blame [__]
oh yeah that's wild he wow for that and
the dude the black dude was confused he
was like I gotta snuff him but he's gay
he's crazy that you can get away with
anything as long as you're gay watch
this slay [__] yeah yeah slay [__]
slay [__] ass [__]
that is so crazy
so yes you just gotta do that